pixar's soul is about a jazz pianist who
finds out there's a lot more to
existence than he ever imagined
and there's a lot more to seoul than
viewers probably noticed at first glance
whether they're referencing pixar films
or real-life heroes
here are the easter eggs you may have
missed in seoul
when joe meets 22 we're treated to
flashbacks of some of the mentors who
tried and failed to get them ready to
take their place on earth
we learned that a diverse group of
departed souls including those of mother
teresa muhammad ali
and copernicus tried and failed to
mentor 22
later when 22 brings joe to their home
joe stops to check out a wall covered
with name tags displayed like trophies
of all the mentors who failed to bring
22 to heal it will take the pause button
and some patience to read a good
percentage of the names displayed but
they include
writers revolutionaries painters and
baseball legends among others
joe clearly isn't the first person in
the music world that 22 has met
since tags for aretha franklin marvin
gaye and johnny cash
are on the wall albert einstein and
stephen hawking are up there too
as are amelia earhart babe ruth pablo
picasso
martin luther king jr and harriet tubman
there are also some names that wouldn't
be as recognizable
for one the game-changing marvel comics
artist jack kirby was apparently one of
22's mentors
two late disney greats also make the
grade joe raft co-wrote toy story and
was an actor with voice acting credits
in a bug's life
cars the incredibles and more his name
is on 22's wall
along with that of joe grant a writer
and artist who worked on numerous
animated films
including fantasia lady in the [ __ ] and
mulan
internet startups don't always have the
best track records but there's at least
one fictional startup that's doing
pretty well
in 2015's inside out a pixar film that
was co-directed by seoul's pete doctor
riley's father works for the company
brang and he proudly wears their
t-shirts
in one of seoul's subway scenes
advertisements for brang
are among many lining the inside of the
subway car you never get a complete
shot of the entire ad but you see bits
and pieces of it
including its achingly corny slogan what
did you bring
hang on hang on what are y'all laughing
at the brain ad
isn't the only pixerrific easter egg in
the subway tunnels
while 22 is mesmerized by the music of a
street performer the number 2319 is
visible behind
and above the singer's shoulder on the
side of the subway car
fans of 2001's monsters inc doctors
feature film directorial
debut may remember 2319 as the code
that's used to signal when a human
contaminant is found in the world of
monsters
george and i are like brothers 23 19.
we have a 23-19 one of the many wonders
that joe sees in the great before
is the hull of everything a place meant
to help new souls find their spark
hall of everything is also chock full of
fun easter eggs
it's practically a law that you can't
release a pixar film without adding the
pizza planet delivery truck that made
its first appearance in 1995's toy story
for example it's just barely visible
outside the dentist's office in finding
nemo
it's in the speedway parking lot in cars
and it even shows up in the distant
future of
wall-e and yeah it also makes an
appearance in seoul
the truck is in the first scene
featuring the hull of everything and it
isn't the only wall-e veteran in the
place either you can spot the starliner
spacecraft axiom in the distance
and the spirit of adventure blimp from
2009's up has taken to the air as well
you can also spot the ferris wheel from
toy story 4
an aztec building from coco and there's
doubtless
even more goodies than we are able to
catch and a couple of shots later
you can even see the iconic desk lamp
from the short film
luxo jr standing next to a grand piano
it isn't easy to spot but the hull of
everything includes another classic
pixar easter egg
on a street sign below the ferris wheel
from toy story 4
eagle-eyed viewers will spot a113
something you can find
in almost every pixar film a113 is a
code that comes up a lot in wall-e
it's andy's mom's license plate number
in the toy story flicks and it shows up
on a diver's camera
in finding nemo so what does it mean at
california institute of the arts
a113 was the room number of the
animation classroom
filmmakers like john lasseter tim burton
and brad bird were in the school's
animation program
burden fact is credited as the first to
introduce the a113
easter egg using it as a license plate
in the 1985
nbc anthology series amazing stories
which was created by steven spielberg
it's since appeared in a long list of
television shows films
and video games in september 2015
the internet went nuts over the viral
video of a rat dragging an
entire slice of pizza down the stairs of
a manhattan subway
filmed by comedian matt little the video
shows the legendary rat
ultimately running away and leaving the
pizza behind proving they can honor more
than their own animated films
the folks at pixar decided to include a
tribute to the mighty pizza rat
in seoul shortly after joe and 22 get to
earth
with 22 in joe's body and joe's own soul
inhabiting the form of a therapy cat
they escaped the hospital and make their
way to the streets of new york city
the metropolis is too much for 22 at
first
the crowds the cars and all the other
stimuli of city life
overwhelm the inexperienced soul as a
result
22 tries to lose joe but he finds them
hiding in a corner
totally shaken hoping to calm them down
joe creeps over to a nearby pizzeria and
swipes a hot slice for 22 but joe isn't
the first one with the idea
as he brings the slice back to 22 a
rodent who can only be the mighty
pizza rat shows up coming from the other
direction dragging his own slice across
the concrete
apparently pizza rat has learned some
courage since the 2015 video
he's understandably spooked when he
spots joe but this time he keeps his
jaws on the prized pizza
as he inches away from the cat in their
hideout in the great before
22 has amassed a small collection of
stuff presumably swiped from the hall of
everything
when they show joe their place we see an
alarm clock a jukebox
and a sofa but among all the items
stashed away in 22's place
there's a toy ball that should be very
familiar to pixar fans
and animation historians this is the
ball from john lasseter's 1986 short
film
luxo jr the source of the iconic desk
lamp that takes the place of the eye
in pixar's animated logo the short
animation features two desk lamps an
elder lamp and a smaller baby lamp
the baby lamp plays with a bright ball
that's decorated with a red star
eventually jumping on the ball and
deflating it the film ends as the baby
lamp finds a much bigger ball to play
with
it's the smaller ball 22 keeps in her
hideout
while it's likely not meant to have any
extensive backstory behind its presence
in seoul
it is kind of funny the ball not only
shows up but it's been reinflated
maybe like joe it was on its way to the
great beyond but somehow found itself to
the great before
in the wondrous land of the great before
the new souls aren't left completely to
their own devices
along with their mentors the young souls
are guided by their large
caring shape-shifting counselors the
counselors are voiced by five different
actors
but they're all named jerry the spelling
is different but this is likely a nod to
pixar's 1997 short film
jerry's game considering that soul
director pete doctor was an animator on
the short
noteworthy for being pixar's first film
in which a human is the lead character
jerry's game features an elderly man
playing a game of chess
against himself in a park jerry's game
was also pretty successful in its own
right
winning the oscar for best animated
short film in 1998
the great before his vetting process
clearly needs a little work
because joe is able to pass himself off
as eminent child psychologist
dr borgensen just by swiping the good
doctor's name tag
when 22 still believes joe is lying
about not being borgenson
they call up the doctor's history in the
hall of you a place which displays
meaningful slices of
any person's life among the pieces of dr
borgensen's life
is a statue depicting the doctor holding
the hand of a young child
and motioning toward the distance this
is a pretty blatant reference to
partners
a statue appearing in a number of
disney's theme parks
first erected in 1993 the copper statue
looks very similar to morgansen's
except that in the doctor's place is
walt disney and in the child's place is
disney's most iconic creation
mickey mouse it does make you wonder
considering how important this borginson
guy appears to be
what exactly happened to him we never
hear from him once
joe grabs his name tag it seems likely
he's at an information kiosk somewhere
in the great before
filing a complaint with one of the many
councilor jerry's
right after joe finds himself heading to
the great beyond
there's a line of dialogue that
absolutely screams easter egg
however its origin isn't completely
clear when joe runs into a trio of souls
likewise heading to their eternal reward
one of them says
this beats my dream about the walrus so
yeah what's up with that
it seems the most likely possibility is
this is a reference to the walrus and
the carpenter a song from disney's 1951
film
alice in wonderland the song tells the
story of a walrus and a carpenter who
lure a group of oysters to their doom
at a dinner table while both walrus and
carpenter are both hoping to partake
the walrus devours all the oysters
before his companion gets a bite
so going back to pixar it could be that
the newly departed soul had a dream in
which she was one of the selfish
walruses oysters
it's possible it could also reach back
to the source material
lewis carroll's 1871 novel through the
looking glass
some interpret the walrus and carpenter
as religious figures
which would be exactly the type of
people you might expect to meet in the
afterlife
it's also worth noting that lewis
carroll's trippy tale is one of the
inspirations for the beatles
1967 song i am the walrus
asked about what the walrus represented
in the song john lennon answered
walrus is just saying a dream along with
its other memorable recurring easter
eggs pixar is known for adding
references
not only to its past movies but its
upcoming ones as well
soul proves to be no exception when joe
and 22 pass by a travel agency in new
york city
one of the posters in the agency's
window encourages you to
visit porto rosso anyone who's been
keeping up with upcoming pixar features
knows
this is most likely a reference to the
2021 film luca which is reportedly set
in a seaside town on the italian riviera
that resembles the fictional porto rosso
the title's namesake is a young boy
living in italy whose best friend is a
sea monster in human form
luca is set to release june 18th 2021
according to a member of the pixar post
forums disney in 2020
also filed several public copyrights
that included the words
luca porteroso if true it wouldn't be
the first time that pixar foreshadowed a
future movie in an easter egg
soul in fact had its own pre-release
easter egg in onward
the family's vinyl collection features a
record by dorothea williams
the same famous jazz artist joe is so
desperate to play with
in seoul check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite pixar movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one